That boy needs therapy. Psychosomatic. That boy needs therapy. You're psychosomatic. That boy needs therapy. Lie down on the couch. That boy needs therapy. Hi y'all, it's Joel Blackstock with the Taboo Therapy Collective podcast. We've been doing some articles and podcasts on the psychology of different parts of art and design. And then in July, we're going to sit down with Will Selman, who is a friend that's doing a book about Jungian psychology being fused with urban planning, which is a very taproot therapy type guest to have. So we'll sit down with him in July. And today I'm doing an article about chairs. So the article from the blog, and there's pictures of these chairs and
那个男孩需要治疗。身心失调。那个男孩需要治疗。你这是身心失调。那个男孩需要治疗。躺在沙发上。那个男孩需要治疗。大家好，我是Taboo Therapy Collective播客的乔尔·布莱克斯托克（Joel Blackstock）。我们一直在制作关于艺术和设计不同部分的心理学文章和播客。七月份，我们将与威尔·塞尔曼（Will Selman）坐下来聊聊，他是一位朋友，正在写一本关于荣格心理学与城市规划融合的书，这对于“根源疗法”（taproot therapy）来说是非常合适的嘉宾人选。所以我们七月份会和他进行访谈。今天我写了一篇关于椅子的文章。博客上有这些椅子的图片，
different, more information as always in the article than there is on the podcast and pictures. But if you want to look at the blog, you can, you can read that. And the article that we're going to read today is called, You May Address the Chair. What We Sit In Tells Us What We Stand For. So what do chairs say about culture, personality, and psychology? You might notice that you and your therapist both have to sit in a chair when you go into therapy. You know, we have internalized this visual language of therapy. You know, I don't have to tell people where they're supposed to sit when they come in. They understand.
和往常一样，文章里的信息比播客和图片里的要多。但如果你想看博客，你可以去读一读。我们今天要读的文章标题是《你可以向椅子致意：我们坐在什么上面，就代表我们坚持什么》（You May Address the Chair. What We Sit In Tells Us What We Stand For）。那么，椅子能说明关于文化、个性和心理学的什么问题呢？你可能注意到，当你去接受心理治疗时，你和你的治疗师都必须坐在椅子上。你知道，我们已经内化了这种治疗的视觉语言。你知道，当人们进来时，我不需要告诉他们应该坐在哪里。他们自己明白。
When you think of therapy, you think of the couch. We know, even in a picture of people that we don't know, that the therapist sits on a chair and the patient sits on the couch. We upload pictures of our therapy offices for people to see them in therapy directories and websites because we know that the spaces that we design say something about us and we want to communicate that. So I've written a lot about how the he says a lot of things about that the chair is the fastest way to communicate character when you're writing and designing the visuals for a movie. So I'm fascinated with this intersection of design and psychology. You know, design is a powerful indicator of not only personality, but also of how a society sees itself and its future. And one of the reasons that many architects become furniture designers
当你想到心理治疗时，你就会想到沙发。我们知道，即使是在一张我们不认识的人的照片中，治疗师也会坐在椅子上，而病人坐在沙发上。我们会上传治疗室的照片，让人们在治疗名录和网站上看到，因为我们知道我们设计的空间能说明关于我们的一些事情，而我们想要传达这一点。所以我写了很多关于椅子如何成为电影写作和视觉设计中传达角色最快方式的内容。所以我对设计与心理学的这种交叉点非常着迷。你知道，设计不仅是性格的有力指标，也是一个社会如何看待自身及其未来的有力指标。许多建筑师成为家具设计师的原因之一
is that both jobs require that someone have a vision of the future and a hypothesis about the way style, economy, and society are headed. Buildings and furniture, they're not sets for a play. We don't throw them away at the end of the night. We expect them to last often longer than us, and that means that someone must look into the future and make a guess about what kinds of styles and materials will last. And not just practically that you don't want to fall apart, but also stylistically that it still remains beautiful. And some of the largest fights in architecture come from the
是这两项工作都需要一个人对未来有愿景，并对风格、经济和社会的发展方向有假设。建筑和家具不是戏剧的布景。我们不会在演出结束后就把它们扔掉。我们期望它们的使用寿命往往比我们更长，这意味着必须有人展望未来，并对什么样的风格和材料能够持久做出预测。这不仅是实际层面的——你不希望它散架，而且在风格上也要保持美感。建筑界一些最大的争论源于
competing visions of the world and what it could be or it should be. And one of the biggest divides between the schools of architecture and design has been between the classicists and the modernists. And the classicists prefer traditional structures and styles. And classicists believe that these methods evolved over time for a reason. So we shouldn't get rid of tradition. That classicism is an expensive way, you know, to build and it also was slow to change by its nature. So modernism prefers using technology and new materials to create structures that were previously impossible to build. So modernists, sometimes they throw the baby out with the bathwater and trying to discover new possibilities
对世界是什么样或应该是什么样的相互竞争的愿景。建筑和设计流派之间最大的分歧之一就是古典主义者和现代主义者之间的分歧。古典主义者偏爱传统的结构和风格。古典主义者认为这些方法随着时间的推移而演变是有原因的。所以我们不应该抛弃传统。古典主义是一种昂贵的建造方式，而且本质上改变缓慢。因此，现代主义更喜欢利用技术和新材料来创造以前无法建造的结构。所以现代主义者有时会在试图发现新可能性时，把孩子和洗澡水一起倒掉。
and what we can do. And classicism is asking, you know, should we do it? And modernism is asking, can we do it? And both perspectives keep design grounded in both form and function. So the designers that I'm really interested in, I like, this is mainly about the modernist period of chairs, are Charles and Ray Eames. They were one of the most successful furniture designers of all time, worked for the Herman Miller Furniture Company. And Charles Eames was actually an architect who was kicked out of school for being too radical. They didn't like what he was doing. And you may know him from his iconic Eames chair, which was what I sit in in my office.
以及我们能做什么。古典主义在问：“我们应该这样做吗？”而现代主义在问：“我们能做到吗？”这两种视角都使设计扎根于形式和功能之中。所以我真正感兴趣的设计师——这主要关于椅子的现代主义时期——是查尔斯和雷·伊姆斯（Charles and Ray Eames）。他们是有史以来最成功的家具设计师之一，曾为赫尔曼·米勒（Herman Miller）家具公司工作。查尔斯·伊姆斯实际上是一位建筑师，因为太激进而被学校开除。他们不喜欢他的做法。你可能从他标志性的伊姆斯椅（Eames chair）认识他，那也是我办公室里坐的椅子。
And Charles and his wife were very good at predicting the future. And they were so good, in fact, that the Ames chair is one of the longest manufactured and best-selling chairs of all time. And so even though, you know, even some of the work that Charles and Ames did wasn't really received within their life, with the context of history, we can see what they were seeing with their intuition. And we'll get to that. But, you know, even though it was not understood then, it was a warning to us about the risks of hyperconnection and consumption and information technology and a lot of things that we couldn't really hear in the 1980s at the end of their life.
查尔斯和他的妻子非常擅长预测未来。事实上，他们非常擅长，以至于伊姆斯椅是有史以来生产时间最长、最畅销的椅子之一。所以，尽管查尔斯和伊姆斯做的一些工作在他们生前并没有真正被接受，但在历史的背景下，我们可以看到他们凭直觉看到了什么。我们稍后会谈到这一点。但是，你知道，尽管当时人们并不理解，但这对我们来说是一个关于过度连接、消费、信息技术以及许多我们在他们生命末期的1980年代无法真正听进去的风险的警告。
And so their final works were glimpses of the future and what were considered failures. I don't think we should consider failures anymore. Some of their failures, I think, are actually prophecy. And so, you know, Ray Eames was always at the forefront of embracing new technology and pushing the boundaries of design. And so he recognized the power of interconnectedness and the exchange of information. And Ray set out to create an exhibit that would reflect these ideas. So Connections, the work of Ray Eames, was this exhibit that explored the concept of interconnectedness and the forms of design that she did at the end of her life when she was already a very famous designer, one of the
所以他们最后的作品是对未来的瞥见，当时被认为是失败之作。我认为我们不应该再认为那是失败了。我认为他们的一些失败实际上是预言。所以，你知道，雷·伊姆斯总是走在拥抱新技术和突破设计界限的最前沿。因此，他认识到了互联互通和信息交换的力量。雷着手创建一个能够反映这些想法的展览。所以《连接》（Connections），雷·伊姆斯的作品，就是这样一个探索互联互通概念和设计形式的展览，这是她在生命末期，当她已经是一位非常著名的设计师时所做的，她是世界上最
most famous in the world. And Ray saw the similarities between the way that information is organized and the interconnectedness of the design elements and she believed that design should be viewed as a network or a relation or an ideas about relationships between things and um responses and reflections things responding to and reflecting each other like in a neural network and so charles eames's last design was a celebration of the lives of Thomas Jefferson and Benjamin Franklin. And it was at the, this is the guy, this is not Ray, this is Charles Eames' last work. It was called, it was for the bicentennial of the country and it was at the Met. And it was called a celebration of the lives of Thomas Jefferson and Benjamin Franklin. And it was, he grouped, you know, these historic items, all these different artifacts and things from their life, you know, by their associations with each other, but not in these museum-like exhibits where all the items are placed together, you know, that are the same.
著名的设计师之一。雷看到了信息组织方式与设计元素互联互通之间的相似之处，她认为设计应该被视为一个网络、一种关系，或者关于事物之间关系的理念，以及事物之间相互响应和反射，就像神经网络一样。所以查尔斯·伊姆斯最后的创作是对托马斯·杰斐逊（Thomas Jefferson）和本杰明·富兰克林（Benjamin Franklin）生平的赞颂。这是那个家伙，这不是雷，这是查尔斯·伊姆斯最后的作品。它是为了国家的建国两百周年而作，在纽约大都会艺术博物馆展出。它被称为《托马斯·杰斐逊和本杰明·富兰克林生平庆典》。他将这些历史物品，所有这些不同的文物和他们生活中的东西，按它们之间的关联进行分组，而不是像博物馆展览那样，把所有相同的物品放在一起。
You go into one room that's all combs and another room that's all pots. That's not how he did it. And so visitors were encouraged to engage with the exhibits in a non-linear way. You didn't have to go through it only one way. So you could explore connections between different artworks or historical events and cultural phenomenon. And the exhibit employed these innovative techniques such as film projections and audio recordings and tactile displays, what you could touch to create this immersive and participatory experience. Everyone could get what they wanted out of it, not what the designer was wanting you to experience.
你走进一个房间，里面全是梳子，另一个房间全是罐子。他不是那样做的。因此，参观者被鼓励以非线性的方式参与展览。你不必只走一条路。所以你可以探索不同艺术品或历史事件与文化现象之间的联系。展览采用了电影投影、录音和触觉展示等创新技术，你可以触摸它们，创造出这种沉浸式和参与式的体验。每个人都能从中得到他们想要的，而不是设计师想要你体验的东西。
And so there were like lines where you could walk through it and see everything from their social life or from their political life or, you know, when they had parties and their friends and society. And you could follow, if you were interested in one thing, a line to another part of the exhibit. I promise this will get back to chairs, but this exhibit was roasted. Nobody got it. Nobody understood it. And the review that the New York Times published, this is an excerpt from that in 1976, said,
所以有一些路线，你可以走过它，看到他们社交生活或政治生活中的一切，或者他们举办派对、朋友和社交圈的情况。如果你对某件事感兴趣，你可以沿着一条线走到展览的另一部分。我保证这会回到椅子的话题上，但这个展览被批评得很惨。没人看懂。没人理解它。这是《纽约时报》1976年发表的一篇评论摘录，上面写道：
It is indeed precisely the kind of bicentennial show that so many of us have dreaded, an elaborate and expensive exercise in nostalgia, rich in picturesque effects, but devoid of anything resembling a serious idea. It is certainly not an exhibit that belongs in the Metropolitan Museum of Art. It belongs in the show windows of IBM. And, you know, I think that's funny because IBM goes on to, what, invent the computer. The internet is about to happen. It's 1970s. We don't know that that's going to happen, but that's what's coming. And so intuitives, they often feel things that can't be explained rationally or intellectually. It's more of somebody analyzing this broad series of patterns. So many of these things, their currents in society or culture and technology, and what some people
“这确实正是我们许多人所恐惧的那种建国两百周年展览，一场精心制作且昂贵的怀旧练习，充满了如画的效果，却缺乏任何类似严肃思想的东西。这绝对不是一个属于大都会艺术博物馆的展览。它属于IBM的橱窗。”你知道，我觉得这很有趣，因为IBM后来发明了计算机。互联网即将出现。那是1970年代。我们不知道那会发生，但这就是即将到来的未来。所以直觉敏锐的人，他们经常能感觉到一些无法理性或理智解释的事情。这更多是某人分析这一系列广泛模式的结果。这些事情中的许多，它们是社会、文化和技术中的潮流，而有些人
call being an empath is really just this deep attunement to systems and small changes in others and in our larger society and what charles and ray eames were feeling but they would never live to see when they did these things about connections and networks at the end of their life that were not very well received is they were intuiting the way that modern technology was about to hyper connect the world in a way that would necessitate the destruction and reinvention of many forms of political social and economic systems technology was about to hyper connect the world in a way that would necessitate the destruction and reinvention of many forms of political, social and economic systems. Ray Eames's exhibits were visions of something called hypertext.
称之为“共情者”（empath），实际上只是对系统以及他人和我们大社会中微小变化的深刻调谐。查尔斯和雷·伊姆斯在生命末期所感受到的，但他们生前从未能亲眼见证的，是他们凭直觉感受到了现代技术即将以一种需要摧毁并重塑许多政治、社会和经济系统形式的方式，将世界进行超连接。技术即将以一种需要摧毁并重塑许多政治、社会和经济系统形式的方式，将世界进行超连接。雷·伊姆斯的展览是对一种叫做“超文本”（hypertext）事物的愿景。
He was trying to set this up like the internet, except the internet didn't exist. So when you're reading a Wikipedia article and you see Thomas Jefferson as a name and you're like, well, I want to find out more about that. You can click it in this nonlinear way. You don't have to click all the links. You click the one you want, you go to the next thing. And that's how the exhibit was trying to use what he thought future technology would be in a, in, in, in meat space, you know, in, in, in the real world. And people didn't understand it, but you can go back and see this. And it's almost a visual representation of this thing that would be there in four years so this interconnectedness you know it enables us to you know explore information in
他试图把它设置得像互联网一样，尽管当时互联网还不存在。所以当你阅读维基百科文章时，看到托马斯·杰斐逊的名字，你会想：“嗯，我想了解更多关于那个的信息。”你可以用这种非线性的方式点击它。你不必点击所有的链接。你点击你想要的那个，然后进入下一件事。这就是展览试图在现实世界（meat space）中利用他认为未来技术会是什么样子的方式。人们不理解它，但你可以回过头来看看。这几乎是四年后才会出现的事物的视觉表现。所以这种互联互通，你知道，它使我们能够以
a non-linear and dynamic manner and follow our own interests and make our own connections and create a personalized and associative way of accessing information that's what the exhibits were trying to do and that's what the internet is. You know, it's this nonlinear presentation of information that's personalized and associative. So why am I writing about chairs? It's minds like Charles and Ray Eames, who made the most famous chair of all time, that I find so interesting when you pull it back to psychology and then you, you, you, you know, so much of this podcast and, um, a lot of the way that I want us to revision psychology is to see it,
一种非线性和动态的方式探索信息，追随我们自己的兴趣，建立我们自己的联系，并创造一种个性化和联想式的信息获取方式。这就是展览试图做的事情，也是互联网的本质。你知道，这是一种个性化和联想式的非线性信息呈现。那么我为什么要写椅子呢？正是像查尔斯和雷·伊姆斯这样创造了有史以来最著名椅子的人，当我把它拉回到心理学时，我发现他们非常有趣。而且，你知道，这个播客的很大一部分，以及我希望我们重新审视心理学的方式，是将其视为，
not just as this thing you go to, cause you're a hurt puppy and then you get better and you're sick, but it's a part of life and art and growth. And then the Z east of culture of myth of design of storytelling, you know, why the books that are on the New York times bestseller list are there that month, all of that is part of psychology.
不仅仅是你因为受伤而去看的东西，然后你变好了，你生病了，它是生活、艺术和成长的一部分。还有文化的时代精神、神话、设计、叙事，你知道，为什么《纽约时报》畅销书排行榜上的书会在那个月上榜，所有这些都是心理学的一部分。
And, you know, I'm looking for the keys to our psyche in all parts of culture. And chairs seem like one of the most interesting ways to do that. And that's why I love chairs so much. I always joked that I started a therapy practice in order to feed my lounge chair addiction, because we had to buy a lot of chairs that are very nice chairs. But if you look at chair design in any period in history, especially chair designers, you'll get some of the most relevant details of interesting people of that period. So, you know, chairs might seem like these innocuous necessities at first, but when you really sit with it, you know, the role that they play becomes much more important. I had a Latin professor tell me one time that the words that we never use don't change.
而且，你知道，我在文化的各个部分寻找我们心灵的钥匙。椅子似乎是做到这一点最有趣的方式之一。这就是我为什么如此热爱椅子的原因。我总是开玩笑说，我开办心理治疗诊所是为了满足我对休闲椅的沉迷，因为我们必须购买很多非常好的椅子。但如果你观察历史上任何时期的椅子设计，尤其是椅子设计师，你会得到那个时期有趣人物的一些最相关的细节。所以，你知道，椅子起初看起来可能只是这些无害的必需品，但当你真正坐下来思考时，你知道，它们所扮演的角色变得重要得多。我曾有一位拉丁语教授告诉我，我们从不使用的词汇是不会改变的。
Those words stay the same for 100,000 years. The words that we use often, they change very quickly, so they don't last very long. So think about that. You know, the slang that was cool when you're in high school that's used a lot, you know, that's not copacetic anymore. It's not groovy. You know, those words lose their meaning or association pretty quickly. So, you know, words change because new generations, new social attitudes, new technologies and new kinds of experiences mean that the most frequently used words will be modified or replaced
那些词汇在十万年里保持不变。我们经常使用的词汇，它们变化得非常快，所以它们不会持续太久。所以想想看。你知道，你高中时很酷、使用频率很高的俚语，你知道，现在已经不再流行了。它不再时髦了。你知道，那些词汇很快就会失去它们的意义或联想。所以，你知道，词汇会改变，因为新的一代、新的社会态度、新的技术和新的经验意味着最常用的词汇会被修改或替换。
first. And chairs are the same way. They're a piece of furniture that most people will be the most likely to use in most settings. You know, you don't always interact with a refrigerator. You don't always interact with a bed in every building that you go into. You usually interact with a chair. If you interact with any furniture anywhere that you go, it's most likely to be a chair. And because chairs are such a necessity, there are also these great barometers for style and culture. What ideas are timeless and what ideas are outdated by the end of the week? Chairs tell you what a place is, what it values, and the social worth of the posterior that they're holding up. The person sitting at the butt that is in that chair, how valuable is it? Is it a student in a school? Is it the pope? Is it the king? The
首先。椅子也是一样。它们是大多数人在大多数环境中都最有可能使用的一件家具。你知道，你并不总是与冰箱互动。你并不总是与你进入的每栋建筑里的床互动。你通常会与椅子互动。如果你去任何地方与任何家具互动，那最有可能就是椅子。而且因为椅子是必需品，它们也是风格和文化的绝佳晴雨表。什么想法是永恒的，什么想法在一周内就过时了？椅子告诉你一个地方是什么，它重视什么，以及它们所支撑的臀部的社会价值。坐在那把椅子上的人，那个屁股，有多大的价值？是学校里的学生吗？是教皇吗？是国王吗？
chair tells you that. Chairs are highly symbolic and influential in politics, in myth, in religion, film, storytelling. You know, what was the TV show that was so big? Game of Chairs, right? So, you know, Chairs gives you an immediate context in situations where you might not even realize that you're thinking about a chair. What's going on? You know, you know that this guy is the king because of where he sits. You know that this is the choir in the church and those are the parishioners because of
椅子会告诉你。椅子在政治、神话、宗教、电影、叙事中具有高度的象征意义和影响力。你知道，那部非常火的电视剧是什么？《权力的游戏》（Game of Thrones），对吧？所以，你知道，椅子在某些情况下为你提供了一个即时的背景，你甚至可能没有意识到你在思考椅子。发生了什么？你知道，你知道这家伙是国王，因为他坐的地方。你知道这是教堂里的唱诗班，那些是教区居民，因为
where they're seated. You know, the bishop sits here. You know, the chairman sits at the head of the table. If you went over to somebody's house for dinner, you wouldn't just be like, okay, there's six chairs here and sit at the head of the table. You would know that that chair is not for you. You know, the brand and the purpose of your business is communicated based on the chairs. And I know that something is out of date when I go somewhere and now the chairs don't look like they were made this era or they look like something that's not sold anymore. You know, design was always going to be an important part of taproot therapy when we were designing it because it's important to me. And so it was important to me that the style of our brand
他们坐的位置。你知道，主教坐在那里。你知道，主席坐在桌子的首位。如果你去某人家里吃晚饭，你不会只是说：“好吧，这里有六把椅子，坐在桌子首位。”你会知道那把椅子不是给你的。你知道，你的企业的品牌和目的也是根据椅子来传达的。我知道当我走到某个地方时，如果椅子看起来不像这个时代制造的，或者看起来像是已经不再销售的东西，那么它就过时了。你知道，设计一直是我在设计“根源疗法”时的一个重要部分，因为它对我来说很重要。所以对我来说，我们的品牌风格传达出
communicated that we had ideological roots in both the cutting edge brain-based medicines of the future, as well as the holistic and ancient wisdom traditions of the past. And so our, our brand design was the, I joked with Bree that it was going to be, you know, Gandalf's wizard study meets an Apple store, the kind of minimalist modernism with this kind of eclectic old world things. And I told our web designer that our store, our website was going to be Falling Water by Franklin Wright meets a yurt in the Southwest. That was what I wanted it to look like, which confused him until he got what I meant. But not everyone will notice these details when they go into Taproot, but you still feel them. And the things that we don't notice, they often speak louder than the details that we're trying to listen to. So people feel the weight of furniture.
我们既有未来尖端脑科学药物的意识形态根源，也有过去整体和古老智慧传统的根源，这很重要。所以我们的品牌设计，我跟布里（Bree）开玩笑说，它将是“甘道夫的巫师书房遇见苹果商店”，那种极简主义的现代主义与这种折衷的旧世界事物。我告诉我们的网页设计师，我们的网站将是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特（Franklin Wright）的“流水别墅”（Falling Water）遇见西南地区的蒙古包。这就是我想要的样子，这让他很困惑，直到他明白我的意思。但并不是每个人在进入“根源疗法”时都会注意到这些细节，但你仍然能感觉到它们。而我们没有注意到的事情，往往比我们试图倾听的细节声音更大。所以人们能感觉到家具的重量。
I mean, they feel if you sit down in it and your body weight makes the chair scoot across the floor or if it's rock solid because it's heavy and there's real wood in there, as opposed to plastic, even if you can't see it because your body feels the weight of that and it communicates something to you. I mean, you feel the way that light reflects off real wood grain versus laminated, you know, compressed sawdust that has wood printed on it. Your brain, even if you're not thinking about it, does not clock that the same way. It knows that that's not real. People know that, you know, if the same chair at Target that they've seen a whole lot is unique, or if there's kind of a weird piece of art that makes them slow down and think, you know, that space affects you. So you feel these details, even if you don't exactly know
我的意思是，他们能感觉到如果你坐下去，你的体重让椅子在地板上滑动，或者如果它坚如磐石，因为它很重，里面有真正的木头，而不是塑料，即使你看不到它，因为你的身体能感觉到它的重量，它会向你传达一些东西。我的意思是，你能感觉到光线在真正的木纹上反射的方式，与层压的、压缩的锯末（上面印着木纹）相比。你的大脑，即使你没有在思考它，也不会以同样的方式记录它。它知道那不是真的。人们知道，你知道，如果塔吉特（Target）里那把他们见过很多次的椅子是独特的，或者如果有一件奇怪的艺术品让他们慢下来思考，你知道，那个空间会影响你。所以你能感觉到这些细节，即使你并不确切知道
what or why they are. And the spaces that we inhabit affect us unconsciously. And I wanted Taproot to feel different. I wanted it to be a liminal space that slowed you down and made you start to think and feel when you were in the waiting room before you even went into therapy. And that's why all the offices are so different, is they match the style and the personality and the perspective and the modality to a certain extent of each clinician there. You know, my office does not look like Christie's. And most of the styles of chair at Taproot, they come from this modern or mid-century period, which is the design period that we're talking about. That's interesting to me. And these periods, they're interesting to me because they were the celebration of like innovation in furniture design and manufacturing. Even if all the designers in the movement couldn't quite
它们是什么或为什么。我们居住的空间在潜意识里影响着我们。我希望“根源疗法”感觉不同。我希望它是一个阈限空间，让你慢下来，在你进入治疗之前，在候诊室里就开始思考和感受。这就是为什么所有的办公室都如此不同，因为它们在一定程度上匹配了那里每位临床医生的风格、个性和视角。你知道，我的办公室看起来不像克里斯蒂（Christie）的。而且“根源疗法”中大多数椅子的风格都来自这个现代或中世纪时期，这就是我们正在谈论的设计时期。这对我来说很有趣。这些时期对我来说很有趣，因为它们是对家具设计和制造创新的赞赏。即使运动中的所有设计师都不能完全
agree on what that was or where it was going, it was this time of a whole lot of different reinvention. So, you know, how did the mid-century modern furniture movement come about? Well, in the beginning of the kind of mid-20th century, there was this big rise of consumer culture. You know, people weren't just living in the same farmhouse that their granddaddy had lived in and using the same table that he ate at, but they were moving to new cities and new houses, new areas, and buying new furniture. And so they were trying, there were these competing styles that were popping up. There was a lot of consumerism. And there was also this explosion of manufacturing processes that we could
同意那是什么或它将走向何方，这是一个充满各种重塑的时期。所以，你知道，中世纪现代家具运动是如何产生的？嗯，在20世纪中叶，消费文化兴起。你知道，人们不再只是住在他们祖父住过的同一个农舍里，使用他吃饭用的同一张桌子，而是搬到了新的城市、新的房子、新的地区，购买新的家具。所以他们试图，有许多相互竞争的风格正在涌现。有很多消费主义。而且还有制造工艺的爆炸式增长，我们可以
build with new materials, things these different ways that you could mass manufacture. And so there's all this innovation going on. And so with the increasing availability of resources and this desire to figure out what the market wanted, the design became this mean of self-expression and a reflection of this individual taste and lifestyle. And the introduction of innovative materials and production techniques allowed for the creation of chairs that catered to different economic segments you didn't have to you could do fancy chairs not fancy chairs high priced you know all different kinds it didn't all have to just be the same european wooden kitchen chair that most you know houses probably had you know in the 20s um so and you're leaving this period of austerity of war. So there was, so taste is going, the modern era is moving away from the older, you know, very highly Baroque and ornamental styles
用新材料建造，这些不同的方式可以进行大规模制造。所以到处都是创新。因此，随着资源的日益丰富和弄清楚市场想要什么的愿望，设计成为了自我表达的一种手段，是个性化品味和生活方式的反映。创新材料和生产技术的引入，使得创造能够迎合不同经济阶层的椅子成为可能，你不必，你可以做昂贵的椅子，也可以做不昂贵的椅子，你知道，各种各样的，它不必都是20年代大多数房子里可能有的那种欧洲木制厨房椅。所以，而且你正在离开这个战争的紧缩时期。所以，品味正在改变，现代时代正在远离旧的、你知道，非常高度的巴洛克和装饰风格
with gold leaf and carving. And it was moving more towards this minimalistic simplicity. So mid-century modern stuff doesn't have a lot of design. It's very, it looks aerodynamic. It looks like a fast car or fast plane. It has't have a lot of design. It looks aerodynamic. It looks like a fast car or a fast plane. It has the detail shaved off of it. It's very ergonomic.
带有金箔和雕刻的风格。它正朝着这种极简主义的简单性发展。所以中世纪现代的东西没有太多的设计。它看起来符合空气动力学。它看起来像一辆快车或快飞机。它没有太多的设计。它看起来符合空气动力学。它看起来像一辆快车或快飞机。它把细节削减掉了。它非常符合人体工程学。
It was like we had built chairs for 1,000 years. The Rococo or French New Empire style had to have all this elaborate ornamentation to show your social class. And now we don't really care about communicating our social class in that way by saying that we can afford the chair because everyone can afford it so we're trying to talk a different way and that became this style you know that was what was underneath the minimalism of mid-century modern furniture and so a lot of that mid-century modernist movement emerged as a response to the cultural landscape of the 19th century older styles were based on you know extravagant resources of european mobility or mimicking that and then now you know clients were starting to think of what a chair is and what it could be
就像我们已经建造了1000年的椅子一样。洛可可或法国新帝国风格必须有所有这些复杂的装饰来显示你的社会阶层。而现在，我们并不真正关心通过说我们买得起这把椅子来以那种方式传达我们的社会阶层，因为每个人都买得起，所以我们试图用不同的方式交谈，这就是那种风格，你知道，这就是中世纪现代家具极简主义之下的东西。所以很多中世纪现代主义运动的出现是对19世纪文化景观的回应，旧的风格基于，你知道，欧洲贵族的奢侈资源或模仿那种风格，而现在，你知道，客户开始思考椅子是什么以及它可能是什么
and so french and english styles went out of favor and inspired by principles of simplicity and functionality and efficiency new designers champion this idea of honesty in materials, that you didn't do a facade. You didn't try and make it look old even though it was wood, or you didn't paint it to make it so you couldn't tell what kind of what it was. You're going to use wood. That was because you chose it and it was the best material. You're going to make it look as pretty as you could and really showcase the material.
所以法国和英国风格不再受欢迎，受简单、功能和效率原则的启发，新设计师倡导这种材料诚实的理念，即你不做门面。你没有试图让它看起来很旧，即使它是木头做的，或者你没有把它漆成让你看不出它是什么材料。你要使用木头。那是因为你选择了它，它是最好的材料。你要让它看起来尽可能漂亮，并真正展示这种材料。
You weren't going to cover something up and try and hide it in the way that other things used, other styles used those materials as a means to an end, but not as a celebration of the material. And so by showcasing materials in their true form, devoid of unnecessary ornamentation, designers, you know, they aim to reflect the spirit of evolving society. So, um, you know, things like gold or ornamentation and paint were not used to disguise wood. Instead, the wood was celebrated, um, as naturally as you can with an oil or wax. And, you know, this led to this clean stripped down archetypal design. Um, that's, I like archetypal finding archetypal patterns. And a ton of this was like like what do you have to have to
你不会掩盖某些东西并试图隐藏它，就像其他风格使用那些材料作为手段而不是作为对材料的赞美一样。因此，通过以真实形式展示材料，摒弃不必要的装饰，设计师，你知道，他们的目标是反映不断发展的社会精神。所以，嗯，你知道，像黄金或装饰和油漆这样的东西并没有被用来伪装木材。相反，木材被尽可能自然地用油或蜡来赞美。而且，你知道，这导致了这种干净、剥离的原始设计。嗯，我喜欢原始的，寻找原始的模式。而且这其中有很大一部分是，比如，你必须拥有什么才能
be a chair like what is the nature of a chair what can you get rid of and have it still be a chair um you know really trying to find the archetype of chair or the platonic form of chair and so designers like eames they understood the capa the capabilities and the limitations of manufacturing processes and that meant that they could create designs that were both efficient to make, which meant that people could afford them. Because if you make a $5,000 chair, it's not going to be the best selling chair of all time. Even though Herman Miller has jacked the price of the Eames chair up to $5,000, but that's not what it was built to be. It was built to be economic. So they wanted to do something that was both efficient and aesthetically pleasing. And so they use mass production, not to make more money, but to make a higher quality So they wanted to do something that was both efficient and aesthetically pleasing.
成为一把椅子，比如椅子的本质是什么，你可以去掉什么而它仍然是一把椅子，嗯，你知道，真的试图找到椅子的原型或椅子的柏拉图形式。所以像伊姆斯这样的设计师，他们了解制造工艺的能力和局限性，这意味着他们可以创造出既高效制造的设计，这意味着人们买得起。因为如果你制造一把5000美元的椅子，它不会成为有史以来最畅销的椅子。尽管赫尔曼·米勒已经把伊姆斯椅的价格提高到了5000美元，但这并不是它被制造出来的初衷。它被制造出来是为了经济实惠。所以他们想做一些既高效又美观的事情。所以他们使用大规模生产，不是为了赚更多的钱，而是为了制造更高质量的产品。所以他们想做一些既高效又美观的事情。
And so they used mass production not to make more money, but to make a higher quality product available to more people. And so this approach allowed them to create innovative and mass-produced furniture that was affordable and accessible to a wide audience. And so modern and postmodern design generally emphasized the importance of honesty in materials. And honesty in material means the material should be used in its truest form, like I'd said. And, you know, you don't paint plastic to look like wood, which we do now. I don't like that. You know, if you're going to do something with plastic, then do the coolest thing that you can do with plastic. Make a crazy shape. Don't try and make it look like something else. So, you know, during this Cold War era, game theory was really. Um, so, you know, doing the, during this cold war era,
所以他们使用大规模生产不是为了赚更多的钱，而是为了制造更高质量的产品，让更多人能够买到。因此，这种方法使他们能够创造出创新的、大规模生产的家具，这些家具价格实惠，且能被广泛的受众所接受。因此，现代和后现代设计通常强调材料诚实的重要性。材料诚实意味着材料应该以其最真实的形式使用，就像我刚才说的。而且，你知道，你不会把塑料漆成木头的样子，我们现在这样做。我不喜欢那样。你知道，如果你要用塑料做点什么，那就用塑料做你能做的最酷的事情。做一个疯狂的形状。不要试图让它看起来像别的东西。所以，你知道，在这个冷战时期，博弈论真的。嗯，所以，你知道，在冷战时期，
their game theory was really big, which is, uh, you know, during the cold war, they were trying to figure out how to win the cold war basically. And so there's all this game calculation and ideological stuff. And so furniture, uh, and, and modern art was seen as this thing that showcased American individuality in a way that socialists, communists couldn't do that because they had to make everything the same. We were showcasing our individuality and they were trying to make everything the same. So a ton of this was very celebrated and very political at the time. It's come out now that the CIA actually was paying for a bunch of this stuff, like Jackson Pollock, a lot of these people that were these crazy modern artists, which is funny because you
他们的博弈论非常大，也就是，嗯，你知道，在冷战期间，他们基本上是在试图弄清楚如何赢得冷战。所以有所有这些博弈计算和意识形态的东西。因此，家具，嗯，和现代艺术被视为展示美国个人主义的东西，以一种社会主义者、共产主义者无法做到的方式，因为他们必须让一切都一样。我们正在展示我们的个性，而他们试图让一切都一样。所以这其中有很大一部分在当时是非常受赞誉和非常政治化的。现在已经曝光，中央情报局（CIA）实际上是在为很多这样的东西买单，比如杰克逊·波洛克（Jackson Pollock），很多这些疯狂的现代艺术家，这很有趣，因为你
see that a lot of conservative people now are like harking back to tradition, don't like modern art. But then it was all the, you know, buzz cutted military guys that were paying the modern artists in order to show that, you know, this thing was possible in America that was not possible somewhere else. My one, another one of my favorite designers of this period, I know you can't see the pictures because you're not on the blog, but is Adrian Pearsall. If you Google his couches, um, his, uh, I, I don't think they do anything with it. I know restoration hardware like owns the rights to his name. I've never seen them put it on anything.
看到现在很多保守派人士都在呼吁回归传统，不喜欢现代艺术。但当时，正是所有那些，你知道，留着平头的军人，他们在为现代艺术家买单，为了证明，你知道，这种事情在美国是可能的，而在其他地方是不可能的。我最喜欢的这个时期的另一位设计师，我知道你看不到图片，因为你不在博客上，但他就是阿德里安·皮尔索尔（Adrian Pearsall）。如果你谷歌他的沙发，嗯，他的，我，我不认为他们用它做任何事情。我知道Restoration Hardware拥有他名字的权利。我从来没见过他们把它放在任何东西上。
So I don't, I don't know if it would be cool if they still did replicas of his things as I would actually buy something from restoration hardware or West Elm if that was what they did. But no. So yeah, he did couches though. And so he was like very influenced by water and boats. And so his couches looked like oceans that kind of rippled throughout the room. Or like some of them look like gondolas, like they're floating and um a lot of the design language of mazda mazda has all these ripply patterns in their cars it comes from him um the the mazda design language is called nagare
所以我不知道，如果他们仍然制作他作品的复制品，那会很酷，如果他们那样做，我实际上会从Restoration Hardware或West Elm购买东西。但没有。所以是的，他确实做了沙发。所以他深受水和船的影响。所以他的沙发看起来像在房间里荡漾的海洋。或者像其中一些看起来像贡多拉，就像它们在漂浮，而且，嗯，马自达（Mazda）的很多设计语言，马自达在他们的车里有所有这些波纹图案，它来自他，嗯，马自达的设计语言被称为“流”（Nagare）
um but it has uh anyway he was very influential too if uh you want to google him he's his stuff is very pretty so there's this strong emphasis on individual expression and the celebration of uniqueness and some iconic modernist pieces you know achieve this delicate balance between form and function there's a ton of experimentation going on i don't like all of it i'm not a huge fan of the chrome and black leather and glass and like crazy mixed materials. There's an architect that I really don't like, Le Corbusier and Mize Vandero.
嗯，但它有，嗯，无论如何，他也非常有影响力，如果，嗯，你想谷歌他，他的东西非常漂亮。所以这里有一种对个人表达的强烈强调和对独特性的赞美，一些标志性的现代主义作品，你知道，在形式和功能之间取得了这种微妙的平衡。这里有很多实验正在进行，我不喜欢所有的实验。我不是铬合金、黑色皮革、玻璃和疯狂混合材料的超级粉丝。有一位建筑师我真的不喜欢，勒·柯布西耶（Le Corbusier）和密斯·凡·德·罗（Mies van der Rohe）。
And they have this like almost HR Geiger, like cold machine-like thing. Because I think what they were thinking that the future was, was not what the Eames were looking at, which was, you know, this synthesis of the community of the office or the community of the home. And they thought it was going to be like technology and cold and machines. And so they like put Chrome on all this stuff. And I just,
他们有这种几乎像HR吉格（HR Geiger）一样的、冰冷的机器般的东西。因为我认为他们认为未来是什么，并不是伊姆斯夫妇所看到的，也就是，你知道，办公室社区或家庭社区的这种综合体。他们认为未来会像技术、冰冷和机器一样。所以他们喜欢在所有这些东西上放上铬合金。而我只是，
I don't, you see that show up as mid-century modern furniture, but it just looks so dated and like eighties mod to me. Like I, I can't do it. So not all of this stuff I think is, it's good. Um,
我不，你看到它作为中世纪现代家具出现，但它对我来说看起来太老套了，就像八十年代的摩登风格。就像我，我做不到。所以并不是所有这些东西我认为都是，它是好的。嗯，
but it is an interesting period just cause there's so much experimentation going on. So German, Hannah Arendt is a German philosopher and she argues that humans exist in this condition of what she calls natality, meaning that each person is born into a unique world and they have the capacity to initiate something new from their unique perspective. And for Arendt, the world is the space where individuals can create and establish their own identities and engage with others and participate in meaningful activities.
但这确实是一个有趣的时期，因为有太多的实验正在进行。所以德国人汉娜·阿伦特（Hannah Arendt）是一位德国哲学家，她认为人类存在于她所称的“出生性”（natality）状态中，意思是每个人都出生在一个独特的世界中，他们有能力从他们独特的视角发起新的事物。对于阿伦特来说，世界是个人可以创造和建立自己身份、与他人互动并参与有意义活动的场所。
And culture is formed through human activities such as labor, work, and action. So those are sacred and important functions. And the environment plays a crucial role in shaping and influencing individuals' experiences. So Arendt recognized that the world is a dynamic and interactive space that individuals engage with. And the environment provides this context and conditions for human action and facilitates the development of individual and collective identities. So, I mean, one way of saying that is that the spaces we inhabit and work in, you know, need to be more than practical because they affect us and they're kind of the point of life to a certain extent. And they, they, what you, where you work affects how you live at home and how you live at home
文化是通过人类活动形成的，如劳动、工作和行动。所以这些是神圣且重要的功能。环境在塑造和影响个人经历方面起着至关重要的作用。所以阿伦特认识到，世界是一个个人与之互动的动态和交互空间。环境为人类行动提供了这种背景和条件，并促进了个人和集体身份的发展。所以，我的意思是，说这话的一种方式是，我们居住和工作的空间，你知道，需要不仅仅是实用的，因为它们影响着我们，而且它们在某种程度上是生活的意义所在。而且它们，它们，你工作的地方影响着你在家里的生活方式，而你在家里的生活方式
affects how you work and vice versa. That all of these spaces are in communication with each other because they're part of our psychology, and we need to be mindful about them is maybe a way of making that sound a little bit less like a college essay. But, you know, another one of my favorite authors, Robert Pogue Harrison, he writes that, you know, design and architecture, they're not just merely utilitarian or functional, but they're imbued with a cultural and aesthetic significance. You know, he suggests that our living spaces reflect and shape our sense of belonging, our identity, our connection to the world. And he examines the ways in which architecture and design influence our experiences of being at home and the impact our surroundings have on
影响着你的工作方式，反之亦然。所有这些空间都在相互交流，因为它们是我们心理学的一部分，我们需要对它们保持正念，这也许是一种让它听起来不那么像大学论文的方法。但是，你知道，我最喜欢的另一位作家罗伯特·波格·哈里森（Robert Pogue Harrison）写道，你知道，设计和建筑，它们不仅仅是功利或功能的，而是被赋予了文化和美学意义。你知道，他认为我们的生活空间反映并塑造了我们的归属感、我们的身份、我们与世界的联系。他审视了建筑和设计影响我们居家体验的方式，以及我们的环境对
our well-being. And when he talks about chairs in a book on design, he says that, you know, they mediate between the body and the environment. You know, the chair is the thing that connects you to the room. You're not touching the wall. You're not touching the ceiling. You're intimately connected and supported by the chair. So it's connecting you to the building and it is an anchor between you and the building. And so the tools we use, especially the most essential ones, they're either successfully connecting you to growth and beauty or they're failing to. And we just say a chair is a chair. And I don't think that. I think we should bring some intentionality to our space. And many people make the case that these lounge chairs that I'm talking about, they cost exorbitant
我们的幸福感产生的影响。当他在一本关于设计的书中谈到椅子时，他说，你知道，它们在身体和环境之间起到了中介作用。你知道，椅子是连接你和房间的东西。你没有接触墙壁。你没有接触天花板。你与椅子有着亲密的联系并得到它的支撑。所以它把你连接到建筑物上，它是你和建筑物之间的锚。因此，我们使用的工具，尤其是那些最基本的工具，它们要么成功地将你连接到成长和美，要么就失败了。而我们只是说椅子就是椅子。我不这么认为。我认为我们应该给我们的空间带来一些意图。而且许多人认为我正在谈论的这些休闲椅，它们价格昂贵
sums of money. And the Eames chair, Herman Miller, because it's famous, they jacked the price way up. But the Eames is when they were alive. I would recommend getting one if you want one from another manufacturer. It's in the common domain. Someone else can make them. There's a lot of companies that make them just as good and for a lot less. There's some cheap versions, but that's kind of an aside. I mean, that point that this stuff is just for the ultra wealthy art guy to play around with, I would push back against that because some of these chairs are ostentatious or
金钱。至于伊姆斯椅（Eames chair），因为赫尔曼·米勒（Herman Miller）品牌太出名，他们把价格抬得很高。但伊姆斯椅是在他们活着的时候设计的。如果你想买，我建议从其他制造商那里购买。它属于公共领域，别人也可以制造。有很多公司制造的椅子质量同样好，价格却低得多。虽然也有一些廉价版本，但这有点题外话了。我的意思是，对于那种认为这些东西只是超级富有的艺术爱好者玩物的观点，我持反对态度，因为其中一些椅子虽然浮夸，或者
they're stupid or the prices are stupid, but that's largely just because some of these are rare antiques or they're made by the few remaining companies that still employ people to build things. You know, again, we have forgotten what design means. I feel, you know, like most of the chairs that we have at Taproot, I didn't pay anything for, um, you know, they belong to family or friends who are moving out or, you know, people who donated them. And then they would say, Oh, you want this, this is all beaten up and old. And I was able to restore it and fix it. Um, a lot of it came from garage sales. You know, if you, if you learn about this stuff, you sort of know how to fix it
它们很愚蠢，或者价格很离谱，但这很大程度上是因为其中一些是稀有的古董，或者是少数几家仍然雇人制造东西的公司生产的。你知道，我们再次忘记了设计的含义。我觉得，你知道，就像我们在Taproot拥有的大多数椅子一样，我没花什么钱，嗯，你知道，它们属于搬走的朋友或家人，或者，你知道，捐赠它们的人。然后他们会说，哦，你想要这个吗，它已经破旧不堪了。我能够修复它。嗯，很多东西来自车库旧货甩卖。你知道，如果你了解这些东西，你就会知道如何修复它
and what it's worth. And, uh, you know number 71 in the new neurostimulation and brain mapping room that we refinished, they needed work, but they were designed to be worked on because they weren't built to be thrown away. We build everything now. They were built to last forever. And things that we love, they need work. And things with no value, we throw away. We pretend that this thing that's disposable that I'm going to throw in the trash in a year is so important. with no value we throw away. You know, we pretend that like this
以及它的价值。而且，嗯，你知道我们在新装修的神经刺激和脑成像室里的第71号椅子，它们需要修理，但它们被设计成可以修理的，因为它们不是为了被扔掉而制造的。我们现在制造的一切都是为了被扔掉。它们是为永恒而建的。我们所爱的东西需要维护。而没有价值的东西，我们就会扔掉。我们假装这个一年后就会被我扔进垃圾桶的一次性东西非常重要。没有价值的东西我们就会扔掉。你知道，我们假装这个
thing that's disposable that I'm going to throw in the trash in a year is so important. And no, it's not, you're going to chuck it. If it was important, it would be something that you would have with you for your life that your kids would have. And, you know, I have no problem disassembling these chairs and then reassembling them into pieces because they were designed to be timeless and not replace the next year. Um, you know, I think that they're, you know, close to a hundred years old. Like a lot of this stuff came from, um, a relative of mine who, who passed away and I had to buy them from her estate. Um, which, you know, I could have paid the same amount for a chair. They didn't need any work on, on waiver, but I'd be throwing it away because it would be impossible for me to fix it.
一年后就会被我扔进垃圾桶的一次性东西非常重要。不，它不重要，你会把它扔掉的。如果它很重要，它会是你终生相伴的东西，你的孩子也会拥有它。而且，你知道，我拆解这些椅子然后把它们重新组装起来没有任何问题，因为它们被设计成永恒的，而不是为了第二年就被替换。嗯，你知道，我认为它们，你知道，快一百岁了。就像很多这些东西来自，嗯，我的一位去世的亲戚，我不得不从她的遗产中买下它们。嗯，你知道，我本可以花同样的钱买一把不需要任何修理的椅子，但我还是会把它扔掉，因为我根本无法修理它。
So, you know, I have tried and failed before to put together like a brand new $500 table from a modern furniture company that just breaks because it's crap. And you call the company and you're like, I paid $500. This doesn't work. Oh, that's fine. Throw it away. We'll give you another one because they know how much their stuff is worth. It's not worth anything. You know, I was able to take these things that are almost 100 years old and fix them. I can't even put together a brand new $500 table. And I paid $30, you know, for these chairs. And, you know, you see these on Etsy or whatever.
所以，你知道，我以前曾尝试过组装一张来自现代家具公司价值500美元的全新桌子，但失败了，因为它太烂了，直接散架。你打电话给公司说，我付了500美元，这东西没法用。哦，没关系。扔掉吧。我们会给你换一个新的，因为他们知道他们的东西值多少钱。它根本不值钱。你知道，我能够把这些快100岁的东西拿来修复。我甚至无法组装一张500美元的全新桌子。而我只花了30美元，你知道，买了这些椅子。而且，你知道，你在Etsy或其他地方都能看到这些。
The Niles Moller go for a ton. Like, mine are not in great condition. And I refinished them, which probably I didn't do that in a historic way. But, like, I mean, some of them sell for over a thousand dollars and I could throw these on Etsy, but it's important to me that I bring them to Taproot and I share them with you. You know, I love my late godmother very much and I bought them from her estate and she loved Carl Jung. She loved labyrinths. She loved up psychology, a ton of the stuff that we do at Taproot. And when I see them there, I think of her and they're meaningful. It's a space that I want you to feel loved and I want people to feel
Niles Moller的椅子卖得很贵。比如，我的椅子状况不是很好。我重新修整了它们，虽然我可能不是以历史性的方式做的。但是，我的意思是，其中一些卖到了一千多美元，我本可以把这些放到Etsy上卖，但对我来说，把它们带到Taproot并与你们分享很重要。你知道，我非常爱我已故的教母，我从她的遗产中买下了它们，她热爱卡尔·荣格（Carl Jung）。她热爱迷宫。她热爱心理学，我们在Taproot做的很多事情都与此相关。当我看到它们在那里时，我会想到她，它们很有意义。这是一个我想让你感到被爱的地方，我想让人们感到
like it's liminal and numinous and real in a way that I don't feel when I go into a lot of spaces. So myself and other therapists that I've worked with and other practices, we threw out and replaced more money than I spent on everything that taproot has that we haven't thrown any of it away we won't but annually we were throwing away all the wayfair furniture or all the um west elm stuff just does not last they market it as higher end but i don't know why um you know it like they would buy all this stuff and then you would throw it away. And it was like, they really, we would spend like two or three times just a year where we spent total because I buy things that I don't want to ever throw away. And I think
它有一种阈限感、神圣感和真实感，这种感觉我在进入许多其他空间时是感受不到的。所以，我和我合作过的其他治疗师以及其他诊所，我们扔掉并更换的家具比我在Taproot拥有的所有东西花的钱还要多，我们没有扔掉任何东西，我们也不会扔掉。但每年我们都在扔掉所有的Wayfair家具或所有的，嗯，West Elm的东西，它们根本不耐用。他们将其作为高端产品销售，但我不知道为什么，嗯，你知道，他们会买所有这些东西，然后你就会把它们扔掉。这就像，我们一年要花两到三次我们总共花的钱，因为我买的东西是我不想扔掉的。我认为
that is a better way to think about consumption and a better way to think about design. And it's like a lot of people make fun of consumerism and consumption. Well, you know, that isn't inherently a bad thing. The Eames, when they were designing these things, they were trying to make them permanent and timeless. And they wanted to make them as efficient and inexpensive as possible so that people could afford them. And they were important to center their designs on the middle class, but they weren't willing to be so cheap that it was garbage and then it wouldn't be something that would last forever. You know, my kids will inherit that furniture. You know, those chairs connect me to you and one day my children to the beautiful person my godmother was.
这是一种更好的消费思考方式，也是一种更好的设计思考方式。就像很多人嘲笑消费主义和消费一样。嗯，你知道，这本身并不是一件坏事。伊姆斯夫妇在设计这些东西时，他们试图让它们变得永久且永恒。他们想让它们尽可能高效且便宜，以便人们买得起。他们认为以中产阶级为中心进行设计很重要，但他们不愿意为了便宜而制造垃圾，那样它们就不会成为永恒的东西。你知道，我的孩子们会继承这些家具。你知道，那些椅子将我和你联系在一起，有一天也会将我的孩子们与我教母那位美丽的人联系在一起。
And I get so much more pleasure out of that than if they were just kind of plastic folding chairs that you sat in while you did, you know, what I hope is one of the more important things you'll ever do, which is work on yourself therapeutically. So, you know, isn't it sad? It's fun to me to sit with these ideas for a minute and remember a time when people just made things out of love and for the sake of art and self-discovery, even if it's a chair, because what does it do to our mental health to live in a world where everything we eat, everything we watch, everything we put in our house has become dispensable, disposable garbage? We've forgotten what design means. People talk about a beautiful design of an iPhone, design is in quotes there, of their Apple, whatever.
比起那些你在做我希望是你一生中最重要的工作之一——即在治疗上提升自我——时所坐的塑料折叠椅，我从这些椅子中获得了更多的乐趣。所以，你知道，这不可悲吗？坐下来思考这些想法一会儿，回忆起人们仅仅出于爱和艺术与自我发现的目的而制造东西的时代，即使那只是一把椅子，这对我来说很有趣。因为生活在一个我们吃的一切、看的一切、放在家里的一切都变得可有可无、一次性的垃圾的世界里，这对我们的心理健康有什么影响？我们忘记了设计的含义。人们谈论iPhone的美丽设计，设计在这里加了引号，或者他们的苹果产品，等等。
And then they throw it away in a month. Because you don't glue glass that can't be removed to something that is designed well because you glue glass to something that can't be removed when you want someone to crack it and throw it away and get a new one. You know, good design is timeless, even if it is a timeless experience of remembering the way a meal was plated or something. I'm not saying timeless like everything has to last forever. You know, food doesn't. But I still remember eating at Sean Brock's restaurant because it was one of the best meals that I've ever had. And there was so much thought put into everything that he did. You know, it lasted. It was timeless. And, you know, some beautiful designs of software,
然后他们一个月后就把它扔了。因为你不会把无法拆卸的玻璃粘在设计良好的东西上，当你想要别人把它弄碎、扔掉并买个新的时，你才会把玻璃粘在无法拆卸的东西上。你知道，好的设计是永恒的，即使它是一种回忆餐点摆盘方式之类的永恒体验。我不是说永恒就像一切都必须永远持续下去。你知道，食物不会。但我仍然记得在肖恩·布洛克（Sean Brock）的餐厅吃饭，因为那是我吃过的最好的饭菜之一。他所做的一切都倾注了如此多的心血。你知道，它持续了下去。它是永恒的。而且，你知道，一些美丽的软件设计，
hardware come out of Silicon Valley. I'm not saying that a phone doesn't include design. Like I still think about my Sony Ericsson candy bar slider phone from college, but I'm weird, right? Most people are not doing that. Most people who said that their iPhone is beautiful and it's designed so well threw it away. You know, they're not saving it. Realistically, how many of you are framing photos and treasuring these memories of the things that you claim are designed so well? You know, please don't send me the email and be like, well, if you look at the screws on a Samsung phone, they're not in a line, but on Apple, they're all in a line because of design. That's not what design is. Okay. Like it's not, I don't care that the screws are in a line on your
硬件设计来自硅谷。我并不是说手机不包含设计。就像我仍然会想起大学时用的索尼爱立信滑盖手机，但我很奇怪，对吧？大多数人不会那样做。大多数说他们的iPhone很漂亮、设计得很好的人都把它扔了。你知道，他们没有保存它。现实地说，你们中有多少人会把照片装裱起来，珍藏那些你们声称设计得很好的东西的记忆？你知道，请不要给我发邮件说，好吧，如果你看三星手机上的螺丝，它们不在一条线上，但在苹果手机上，因为设计的原因，它们都在一条线上。那不是设计。好吧。就像它不是，我不在乎你的螺丝是否在一条线上
iPhone. Like, um, you know, generally most high technology innovations are not really innovations. Like they're just disguises for triggering humanity's worst addictive and obsessive and competitive tendencies so that you buy a new phone next year because you've just been told that now the future is rounded corners and then next month it's less bezel or whatever. I mean, the design moves in one direction and then it moves back. It doesn't consistently move in a direction with a plan. It's just kind of creating something a little bit different so we can create this itch of I want to get this new thing. And, you know, there are companies that are better and worse at design and, you know, a phone I know is going to be more disposable than a chair. Um, but I hope you hear what I'm saying here. I mean, the reason I think some of this stuff happens is because we got rid of
iPhone上。就像，嗯，你知道，通常大多数高科技创新并不是真正的创新。它们只是为了触发人类最糟糕的成瘾、强迫和竞争倾向的伪装，这样你明年就会买一部新手机，因为你刚刚被告知未来是圆角的，下个月又是更窄的边框之类的。我的意思是，设计朝着一个方向发展，然后又往回走。它并没有带着计划持续地朝着一个方向发展。它只是创造了一些稍微不同的东西，这样我们就能产生一种我想买这个新东西的痒感。而且，你知道，有些公司在设计方面做得更好或更差，而且，你知道，我知道手机比椅子更容易被丢弃。嗯，但我希望你能听懂我的意思。我的意思是，我认为发生这种情况的部分原因是我们要么摆脱了
manufacturing and we kept talking about design. It's not made here. You know, it says on the back of the phone designed by Apple in California, real big made here. You know, it says on the back of the phone, designed by Apple in California, real big, and then real tiny, it says made in China or made in Vietnam. But no, but somebody designed it in California. Well, no, that's not designed. You know, we think that design is something that we can dream up in a vacuum and then outsource all the nitty gritty details of realizing our vision to someone else. And if I tell you, hey, go paint this painting, I'm in California and then you go paint it in China. I'm not an artist. You're the artist. You did it. You know, as Charles and Ray Eames discovered when they built their first chair, you design it as you're manufacturing it.
制造业，要么一直在谈论设计。它不是在这里制造的。你知道，手机背面写着“由加州苹果公司设计”，很大，在这里制造。你知道，手机背面写着“由加州苹果公司设计”，很大，然后很小地写着“中国制造”或“越南制造”。但不，有人在加州设计了它。嗯，不，那不是设计。你知道，我们认为设计是我们可以在真空中构思，然后将实现我们愿景的所有细节外包给别人的东西。如果我告诉你，嘿，去画这幅画，我在加州，然后你去中国画它。我不是艺术家。你是艺术家。你做到了。你知道，正如查尔斯和雷·伊姆斯（Charles and Ray Eames）在制造第一把椅子时发现的那样，你在制造它的同时也在设计它。
You know, the first design that they made, it was too hard for them to build themselves. And so they started over with something that the two of them could build themselves before they sent it to a manufacturer. They drew this thing on paper and they were like, this chair is awesome. It's going to kill, it's going to sell these things. They took it to a manufacturer and they were like, you can't build this. So it wasn't a design, you know, it was a picture of something that they couldn't build. So they, they went back and they got plywood wet and they played with the plywood and they saw that when you got the plywood wet that you could bend it and then you could put it in a kiln and exactly how much could you bend it
你知道，他们做的第一个设计，他们自己很难制造。所以他们重新开始，做了一些他们俩在送给制造商之前自己就能制造的东西。他们在纸上画了这个东西，他们觉得，这把椅子太棒了。它会大卖，它会卖出这些东西。他们把它带给制造商，制造商说，你造不出这个。所以它不是一个设计，你知道，它只是一个他们造不出来的东西的图片。所以他们，他们回去把胶合板弄湿，他们玩弄胶合板，他们看到当你把胶合板弄湿时，你可以弯曲它，然后你可以把它放进窑里，你到底能弯曲多少
and to what variance and what tolerance. And when you did it this way, maybe it looked better, but it didn't last as long. So we can't do it that way. And they figured out, and that's what the Eames chair came out of. There was another chair before the Eames chair. Eames chair was later career, but that's what the origin of their style was, was figuring out what these new processes could actually do. And then doing them, not just drawing something and then saying I'm an artist because they weren't design is part of making it. Um, and the, the And the takeaway here is like, they weren't trying to sell you an Eames chair every year. A lot of the changes on phones
以及达到什么偏差和公差。当你用这种方式做时，也许它看起来更好，但它持续的时间不长。所以我们不能那样做。他们弄明白了，这就是伊姆斯椅的由来。在伊姆斯椅之前还有另一把椅子。伊姆斯椅是他们职业生涯后期的作品，但这就是他们风格的起源，即弄清楚这些新工艺实际上能做什么。然后去做，而不是仅仅画出一些东西，然后说我是艺术家，因为他们不是。设计是制造它的一部分。嗯，而且，这里的要点是，他们并不是想每年都卖给你一把伊姆斯椅。手机上的很多变化
are because they want you to buy a new phone every year. We really don't need to do that. We could replace batteries. We could replace these things. But the word design is used to make you throw something away by these companies. When somebody is using the word to make you put something in the trash and you're calling that design, it's not.
是因为他们想让你每年都买一部新手机。我们真的不需要那样做。我们可以更换电池。我们可以更换这些东西。但“设计”这个词被这些公司用来让你扔掉东西。当有人用这个词让你把东西扔进垃圾桶，而你称之为设计时，那不是设计。
It isn't. Because the Eameses wanted to see a future for the beauty of what the future could be, not to sell it to you. And American brands used to not have planned obsolescence and we moved economy into this place where all all the companies that didn't like maytag the original maytag appliance company they went under because we were rewarding planned obsolescence and design which i think is getting rid of design. You know, Maytag, I don't know if you know, they were a company that built the best washing machine and they lasted forever.
它不是。因为伊姆斯夫妇想看到未来之美，而不是把它卖给你。美国品牌过去没有计划性报废，我们将经济带到了这样一个地方，所有那些不喜欢美泰（Maytag）原始家电公司的公司都倒闭了，因为我们奖励的是计划性报废和设计，我认为这正在摆脱设计。你知道，美泰，我不知道你知不知道，他们是一家制造最好的洗衣机的公司，它们永远不会坏。
I mean, they were built like a tank, but people were inheriting them from their grandparents. And so Maytag wasn't selling enough washing machines. And so they declared bankruptcy and they got bought. And now when you look at the companies that make Whirlpool, Maytag, Wolf, Viking, all of what's KitchenAid, all of those companies, there's only two companies in the world. Those brands are fake. They put the label on. It doesn't really matter. You know, Maytag is still made, but it's just a mark that's owned by one of these two giant planned obsolescent factories. I had a refrigerator broken. The repairman came and he was saying, you know, I could fix this, but they're telling you they make it cost slightly more to replace it than
我的意思是，它们像坦克一样坚固，但人们从祖父母那里继承了它们。所以美泰卖出的洗衣机不够多。于是他们申请破产并被收购了。现在当你看看那些制造惠而浦（Whirlpool）、美泰、Wolf、Viking、KitchenAid的公司时，世界上只有两家公司。这些品牌是假的。他们只是贴上标签。这并不重要。你知道，美泰还在生产，但这只是这两家巨大的计划性报废工厂之一拥有的一个标志。我的冰箱坏了。修理工来了，他说，你知道，我可以修好这个，但他们告诉你，他们让更换它的成本略高于
they do slightly less to replace it than they do to fix it. Cause they don't want me to fix it. They want you to throw it away. And I was like, and he was interesting. And I was like, well, what's the best brand out there? And he was like, man, I've worked for 17. They're all owned by the same company and they do tests. They put grit in the oil and the hinges and they have machines that test hundreds and hundreds of times. How many times can you open this door before it breaks? And he said on these cheaper brands, they'll give it to you for less, but you're going to pay for it in parts and they make sure that their margin is the same. Or you can go out and you can buy the super fancy name brand, you know, Wolf or, uh, I think Viking
修理它的成本略低。因为他们不想让我修好它。他们想让你把它扔掉。我说，他很有趣。我说，那市面上最好的品牌是什么？他说，伙计，我干了17年了。它们都属于同一家公司，他们会做测试。他们在油和铰链里放沙砾，他们有机器测试数百次。在它坏掉之前，你能打开这扇门多少次？他说在这些便宜的品牌上，他们会以更低的价格卖给你，但你会在零件上付出代价，他们确保他们的利润是一样的。或者你可以出去买超级昂贵的品牌，你知道，Wolf或者，嗯，我想Viking
is up there was the sub zeros, the other one. And he was like, and that one will not have any issues, but you're giving them the money up front. They're going to get the money either way. So it doesn't really matter what you buy anymore, which is very sad. You know, to me, it's sad because this stuff started as this way to express individual identity through consumption in a free market. And now that same consumption and consumerism is, you know, on one level, just hyper out of control, but it's also kind of fake. I mean, it doesn't matter if you buy the Maytag or if you buy the Wolf or if you buy the Viking, they're either going to be fixing the cheap thing until they get the same amount of money as if you buy the Maytag or if you buy the Wolf or if you buy the Viking. They're either
是其中之一，Sub-Zero是另一个。他说，那个不会有任何问题，但你要预先付钱。无论如何他们都会拿到钱。所以买什么已经不重要了，这非常可悲。你知道，对我来说，这很可悲，因为这些东西最初是作为一种在自由市场中通过消费表达个人身份的方式。而现在同样的消费和消费主义，你知道，在某种程度上，只是极度失控，但它也有点虚假。我的意思是，无论你买美泰还是Wolf还是Viking，这都不重要，他们要么会一直修理那个便宜的东西，直到他们拿到和你买美泰或Wolf或Viking一样多的钱。他们要么
going to be fixing the cheap thing until they get the same amount of money as if you buy the nice thing. You don't really have a choice. And, you know, being a prophet with, you know, P-H-E-T, like, you know, a prophet like Moses, like I think the Eem, I'm trying to say the spelling, you know, that's different from prophet like money. And I think the EEM, I'm trying to say the spelling, you know, that's different from prophet like money. And I think that these people who are trying to see into the future, it genuinely in the mid-century movement, it generally was to build something that was incredible and to try and see a beautiful future. And now we just pretend that the future is this thing so we can sell you something. But there's not any of that process of design really left.
会一直修理那个便宜的东西，直到他们拿到和你买好东西一样多的钱。你真的没有选择。而且，你知道，作为一个先知（prophet），你知道，像摩西那样的先知，我认为伊姆斯，我是在尝试说拼写，你知道，那和利润（profit）是不一样的。我认为这些试图预见未来的人，在中世纪运动中，它通常是为了建造一些不可思议的东西，并试图看到一个美丽的未来。而现在我们只是假装未来是这个东西，这样我们就可以卖给你一些东西。但并没有剩下任何真正的设计过程。
And, you know, humans want to live in the ego alone. Like we're designed to kind of fall victim to our worst angels. We want to live in fads and trends and hyper consumption and free market capitalism. It exploits all that. And it's why consumerist capitalism will always eschew, it'll skew aesthetic taste towards thoughtlessly modernist design and planned obsolescence because people are threatened by things that take away their ego's control and point them back to a timeless reality and to our own personal significance and things in the face
而且，你知道，人类只想活在自我（ego）中。就像我们被设计成容易成为我们最坏本性的牺牲品。我们想生活在时尚、潮流、过度消费和自由市场资本主义中。它利用了这一切。这就是为什么消费主义资本主义总是会把审美趣味引向轻率的现代主义设计和计划性报废，因为人们受到那些剥夺他们自我控制权并指向永恒现实以及我们在面对神圣事物时个人意义的事物的威胁。
of the numinous. You know, good design is challenging. Another way of saying that is good design is kind of threatening. So it's something that we need, but we don't want, you know, like we want to eat sugar and salt and fat because that's what felt good when we were trying not to starve and we're evolving, but it isn't what we need when we know that. Um, I think we should think of design in the same way that we think of diet. Um, you know, I like good design because it points us back to a greater psychological, spiritual, and transcendental reality. And I believe that we can build a better world than the one where all of our interactions with people and spaces that we inhabit are just transactions. I mean, I think we need to think where we assign value and where we place our identity. And we need to admit that the places that we live and work in affect us and are worth our mindful attention.
你知道，好的设计是具有挑战性的。换句话说，好的设计有点威胁性。所以它是我们需要但又不想要的东西，你知道，就像我们想吃糖、盐和脂肪，因为那是我们在努力不挨饿和进化时感觉良好的东西，但当我们知道这一点时，它并不是我们所需要的。嗯，我认为我们应该像对待饮食一样对待设计。嗯，你知道，我喜欢好的设计，因为它把我们引向一个更伟大的心理、精神和超越性的现实。我相信我们可以建立一个比我们与人以及我们居住的空间的所有互动都只是交易的世界更好的世界。我的意思是，我认为我们需要思考我们在哪里分配价值，在哪里定位我们的身份。我们需要承认我们居住和工作的地方会影响我们，并且值得我们用心关注。
For us, for ourselves, and for others. And not just as practical considerations, but as intuitive, creative projects for us to find our own and our collective humanity's soul. You know, modernist designers sought to break away from tradition and form and create furniture that embodied their personal visions. And this approach resonated with the American spirit of individualism. Breaking old ideas is always a risk, but creation is a risky business. And good design is timeless because it comes from a timeless element and forms in the human psyche that we're making contact with. And it may take generations to map these unseen realms of our collective humanity through our intuition, but we don't always know good design when we see it. But I would argue that we know it when we feel it. And even more so, we know it when it sticks around. The Eames chair is
为了我们自己，也为了他人。不仅仅是作为实际的考虑，而是作为我们寻找自己和集体人类灵魂的直观、创造性的项目。你知道，现代主义设计师试图打破传统和形式，创造体现他们个人愿景的家具。这种方法与美国个人主义精神产生了共鸣。打破旧观念总是有风险的，但创造是一项冒险的事业。好的设计是永恒的，因为它来自人类心理中我们正在接触的永恒元素和形式。通过我们的直觉来绘制这些我们集体人类未见领域的地图可能需要几代人的时间，但我们并不总是在看到好的设计时就能认出它。但我认为，当我们感受到它时，我们就会知道。更重要的是，当它经久不衰时，我们就会知道。伊姆斯椅
here. And I mean, I could throw out some brands from the 50s, but no one would know what they are. Those things are not around. There's a lot of stuff that just sucked and we got rid of it. But the things that stay generally are timeless. And, you know, when Hannah Arendt or Robert Pogue Harrison are talking about those quotes that I read, like they are correct. The changing ourself begins with changing our environment and vice versa. You have to work on your environment while you work on yourself, and changing yourself will also change your environment. But there's a relationship between them.
在这里。我的意思是，我可以列举一些50年代的品牌，但没人知道它们是什么。那些东西已经不存在了。有很多东西很烂，我们已经把它们扔掉了。但留下的东西通常是永恒的。而且，你知道，当汉娜·阿伦特（Hannah Arendt）或罗伯特·波格·哈里森（Robert Pogue Harrison）谈论我读过的那些引语时，他们是对的。改变自己始于改变环境，反之亦然。你在改变自己的同时必须努力改变你的环境，改变自己也会改变你的环境。但它们之间存在着一种关系。
And if you want to start your life, if you want to change your life, start by changing your chair. All right, guys, that was the article on chairs. We've been doing some pieces on design. We'll probably get back to depth psychology and other stuff soon. If you'd like to see another topic, send me an email. And it was never my intention to monetize the podcast or anything. We can just kind of do it as a free resource.
如果你想开始你的生活，如果你想改变你的生活，从换一把椅子开始。好了，伙计们，这就是关于椅子的文章。我们一直在做一些关于设计的文章。我们可能很快会回到深度心理学和其他东西。如果你想看其他话题，给我发邮件。我从来没有打算通过播客赚钱什么的。我们可以把它作为一个免费资源。
That's fun but so total coincidence did not seek out to try and be a brand rep or an influencer but so many people bought the cardio k a rd IEL furniture that we have at taproot because they asked about the woodroo couch that's in my office and down also downstairs and a couple other offices and then some of the chairs. A lot of our furniture kind of came from them. And so anyway, enough people bought it that Cardio asked us if we wanted to be a brand rep, which, you know, I don't really know what we'll do with. Long story short, they gave our business an offer code, which is Taproot. So if you use
这很有趣，但完全是巧合，我并没有寻求成为品牌代表或网红，但很多人买了我们在Taproot拥有的Cardiel家具，因为他们问起我办公室里的Woodroo沙发，楼下还有其他办公室，还有一些椅子。我们的大部分家具都来自他们。所以无论如何，足够多的人买了它，Cardiel问我们是否想成为品牌代表，你知道，我真的不知道我们会怎么做。长话短说，他们给了我们的企业一个优惠码，就是Taproot。所以如果你使用
promo code Taproot, I never thought I would say anything like this on this podcast, but if you use offer code tap root, uh, at cardio.com K A R D I E L, then you get a discount. And we also get some compensation, which we put back towards the business. And that lets us continue to offer therapy at a sliding scale and grow and develop new programs like neuro STEM, which is, you know, a new thing, but, um, probably a risk. And also we're the first people in the state to, to be able to provide that, um, neurostimulation and brain mapping. So anyway, we're developing new programs, uh, and the, any money that we get goes back towards that. So it helps you. It can help us. If you want to buy some of this stuff, uh, I guess
优惠码Taproot，我从没想过我会在这个播客上说这样的话，但如果你在cardio.com（K A R D I E L）使用优惠码tap root，那么你就能得到折扣。我们也会得到一些补偿，我们会把它投入到业务中。这让我们能够继续以滑动比例提供治疗，并发展新的项目，比如神经刺激（neuro STEM），这是，你知道，一个新事物，但是，嗯，可能是一个风险。而且我们是该州第一个能够提供那种神经刺激和脑成像的人。所以无论如何，我们正在开发新的项目，我们得到的任何钱都会投入到其中。所以它对你有帮助。它也可以帮助我们。如果你想买这些东西，嗯，我想
use offer code, uh, taproot at cardio.com. And, um, that's the podcast for this week. I hope you're well, and we'll talk to you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在cardio.com使用优惠码taproot。而且，嗯，这就是本周的播客。希望你一切都好，我们很快会再聊。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。